Herkese merhaba tahmin ediyorum ki
buraya çok güzel motivasyonlarla
gelmişsinizdir bazılarınız için keyifli
bir hafta sonu geçirmek bazılarımızın
içinde Aslında birbirinden güzel ilham
dolu hikayelerdir
burada
aynı aslında
Bugün size yarınımızı daha güzel ve daha
yaşanabilir ve hale getirmek
çok güzel hayallerinizin olduğuna eminim
kariyerimizde yükselmek işte bir cam
Sokak Ayna'nın sahiplenmek iyi bir
eğitim almak sevdiklerimizle vakit
geçirmek veya dünyayı keşfetmek Ama tüm
bu hayallerimizi tehdit eden
ise adında dev bir problemle karşı
karşıyayız
Bugünden itibaren Ne yaparsak yapalım Ne
yazık ki dünyamızın sıcaklığı sıcaklık
ortalaması 2030 yılına kadar
santigrat derece artacak ve ne yazık ki
bunu önlemek için çok değişik abi
Yani anlayacağınız geleceğimizi ve
hayallerimizi tehdit eden bu Global
problemde son Dönemeç sandığımızdan çok
daha yakın
Evet şunu söylüyor olabilirsiniz
hayatımızda ve yaşamımızda bunun cevap
problem ve sorunla mücadele ediyorken
bir yenisini daha eklemek bunların
arasına çok zor duyuluyor olabilirim ama
her geçen gün aleyhimize işleyip Aslında
iklim krizinin problemleri Gün geçtikçe
bizim için daha
yaşanılamaz dünyayı daha yaşanılamaz bir
hale getiriyor tüm bunların arasında
günlük hayatlarımızdaki önceliklerimizi
göz önünde bulundurduğumuz
da öncelikle Kia rararşisinde iklim
krizi ile mücadele etmek bizim için çoğu
zaman öncelikler arasında yer almıyor ve
sırf gündelik dertlerimizde uğraşırken
şunu Kendi içinizde söylüyor
olabilirsiniz Evet Gün geçtikçe biz bu
günümüz halihazırdaki yapıyor olduğumuz
süreçlerde nasıl bu problemle mücadele
edeceğiz ve kazanacağımıza dair
umutlarımızda her geçen gün azalıyor
aslında
Size bir fotoğraf göstermek istiyorum Bu
fotoğraf 2020 yılında
Avustralya'da çekildi ve biliyorsunuz
Avustralya'da 240 gün süren ve 1 milyar
canlının Hayat yaşamını kaybettiği orman
yangınından 1 yıl sonra çekildi Burada
gördüğünüz küçük dostumuzun tohumu
aslında bütün karşılaştığımız zorluklara
ve endişelere rağmen bir şekilde hayatı
sunum köklerine toprağa bırakarak
Aslında güçlü bir şekilde hayatta
kalmaya çalışıyor
bu fotoğraf size neyi çağrıştırıyor
bilmiyorum ama bize tüm olumsuzluklara
rağmen hala bir iklim krizine karşı
veriyor olduğumuz mücadelede hala bir
umudumuzun olduğunu
söylüyor tabi Tüm bunları anlatırken
size biraz kendimden de bahsetsem iyi
olacak gibi Gerçi kim olduğumun bir
önemi yok aslında dünyayı iyileştirmek
için çalışan milyarlarca insandan bir
tanesiyim adım Mert bir bilgisayar
mühendisiyim aynı zamanda da sosyal
girişimciyim Ben Artvin'de doğdum ve
büyüdüm ardından lise için üniversite
için de İstanbul'a geldim akademik
anlamda çok başarılı bir
aldığımız bir sosyal girişimcilik
dersinin bizi Aslında bugünümüzü
şekillendirmesine ve aynı zamanda
geleceğimizi doğrudan geleceğimiz adına
çalışmaya gitti Çünkü dünyanın çevresel
ve sosyal problemlerine çözüm üretme
fikri
gelmişti zamanda da yaşadığım ve
doğduğum şehirde yaşanan çevresel
problemler ailemin ve aynı zamanda o
bölge halkının çevresel konulara karşı
duruşu bizi
ve çevre problemlerine karşı çözümler
aramayı fikir şuydu Eğer yeterli bir
şekilde insanlar bilinçlenirse çevre
konusunda Aslında gelecekte atıyor
olduğumuz adımlarda çevreye duyarlı ve
Sürdürülebilir çözümler bulabiliriz ve
bu
Aslında çevresel problemleri
giderebiliriz Çünkü tamamı insan
kaynaklığıydı örnek veriyorum bir çocuk
bugün çevreye duyarlı bir şekilde
yetiştirildiğinde gelecekte atıyor
olduğu karar verici mercilere geldiğinde
çevresel çevreyle alakalı çevreye
duyarlı anlatmak konusunda bir o kadar
cüretkar olacaktı Biz de tabii ki
üniversitede doğrudan bu fikri
arkadaşlarımıza anlattık ve o zaman hani
mücadele edelim deyip bir dernek kurduk
ve bu dernekle beraberdi Aslında
bireysel çevre bilincini geliştir
ecek ve gerekirse dünyanın bazı
gerçekleri vardı ve biz de bu yüzden
hali hazırda mesleki yeterliliklerimizi
de göz önünde bulundurarak daha farklı
daha Sürdürülebilir çözümler ve
alternatifler geliştirebilir miyiz ve
hayali Şimdi size başka bir fotoğraf
göstereceğim
Sizce bu ağaç Buraya nasıl
İşte
bu Sizler de düşünürken ben fotoğraf
hakkında bir bilgi vereyim bu Burada
gördüğünüz ağaç Aslında Kırım'da şu anda
hatta biliyorsunuz acı bir şekilde
Savaşı da inebiliyor 100-120 yaşında
olduğunu tahmin ediyoruz
Bu ağaç Aslında buraya bir kuş
tarafından geçildi Ee ve bu ağacın
tohumu buradaki kayaların arasına
sıkışarak orada bir şekilde hayatta
kaldı ve bugünkü halini aldı
biliyorsunuz dünyadaki doğal ormanların
tamamı ağaçlardan düşen kozalakların
içerisinden saçılan tohumların Kuşlar
veya rüzgar aracılığıyla Etrafı yayılıp
genişlemiştir Peki biz Aslında
üniversitede arkadaşlarımızla doğrudan
oturup şu sorunun cevabını Çünkü iklim
krizi ile mücadelede ormanların ve aynı
zamanda biyoçeşitliliğin önemi çok fazla
Biz de buna nasıl çözüm üretebiliriz Bu
kuşların yarar kuşların haftası adına
nasıl taklit edebiliriz diye
değerlendirdiğimizde Aslında
[Müzik]
gerçekleştirip iklim krizi ile mücadele
etmeyi amaçladığımız insansız hava
araçlarına ver
diğimiz isim bu insansız hava
araçlarımızı doğrudan üniversite'deyken
geliştirmeye başladık Ve o süreçten bu
sürece de aslında orman ormanlar iklim
krizi biyoçeşitlilik ve çevre konularına
biraz daha eğilmeye başladık Tabii ki
burada ürünümüzü geliştirirken Bu fikir
çok açıktı ve dünyadaki alternatiflerine
uygulanabilir yöntemlere baktık ama bu
bu aslında burada anlatacağım çoğu şey
bizim bu süreçte Bu ürünü nasıl geliştir
ilmişler
deneyine bu Hikayemiz bunu içeriyor daha
sonra bu tohumların başka hangi
parametrelerden etkilendiğine baktı
çünkü
bunu doğrudan incelememiz gerekiyordu Ve
şunu keşfettik ki ve şunu öğrendik ki
tohumlar Aslında çeşitli parametrede
toprağa düştüğü andan itibaren soğuk şu
an Aşırı sıcaktan hayvanların yemesinden
veya
doğrudan rüzgardan etkilenebiliyorlar
Biz de
Bu yüzden ve Burada gördüğünüz Hatta
dünyada geleneksel olarak kullanılan bu
ton topu yöntemini öğrendik Bu aslında
Güney Afrika'da Japonya'da Tayland'ı
uygulanan geleneksel ve toprağın minimum
ve müdahaleye de yapılan bir metot olmuş
bu sayede Aslında bu son topu dediğimiz
şey içerisindeki mineral toz gübre ve
orman toprağı bulunan ve tohumu doğrudan
kaplayan ve tohumun çimlenene kadar ki
geçen sürede aşırı sıcaktan hayvanların
yemesinden aşırı soğuktan veya rüzgardan
koruyarak onların çimlenebilecekleri
çimenine kadar geçen sürede En kornakta
ortamı yaratmayı Hedef
daha sonra biz bu konuyla alakalı hemen
işte provalara başladık Ve denemeye
başladık bunları doğrudan böyle elde
içlerine tohum koyup yuvarlıyorduk
aslında aynı
mantı yapar gibi daha sonra
etrafı Ben az önce bahsettiğim gibi
Artvin de doğduğum büyüdüğüm için
oradaki bölge
halkı ile doğrudan bu formatlarını
üretirken de
komşularımızla
süreçte değerlendirdik aynı zamanda ve
şunu gördüm Aslında iklim krizi şu an
şehirde yaşıyoruz ve iklim krizinin
etkilerini biraz daha az hissediyor
olabiliriz bazı durumlarda
ama yaşayan insanlar iklim krizinden
kaynaklı doğrudan etkileniyorlar Çünkü
eskisi kadar tarım ve hayvancılık
yapamıyorlar Bu sebeple de gerek göç
riskiyle gerekti ekonomik eşit eskisi
kadar gelir elde Edem
edikleriyle karşılaşıyorlardı Biz de
aslında buton topunu yapmak bayağı böyle
evde yapılabilir ve Daha sonrasında işte
saklanabilir toplanabilir halde bize
dedik ki bu etkiyi neden daha fazla
insana ulaştırmayalım Ama bu insanları
alternatif çözümler yaratmayalım Biz de
bu yüzden aslında tohum toplarımızı Ekim
sahalarımıza yakın bölgelerde yaşayan ve
öncelikli iklim krizinden dezavantaja
uğrayan kadınlar
da ton topu üretimi
için
materyaller geliştirdik bunların
eğitimini verdik ardından Onlar bu ton
toplarını malzemelerini veriyoruz son
toplarını yapıyorlar ve ardından Biz
onlardan satın alma gibi bir refleksimiz
oldu bu sayede onların alternatif gelir
kaynaklarına erişmelerini sağlarken
iklim kriziyle hep beraber mücadele
edebil ve daha sonraki süreçlerde gerek
ekolojik bilimi Aslında çok Muti
disiplinler ve karmaşık bir yapı doğayı
anlamak ve anlamaya çalışmak bile başlı
başına bir ömür gerektiriyor ve bununla
alakalı da gerek devlet durumları gerek
üniversitelerde beraber çalışarak her
geçen gün Aslında doğadan
öğrendiklerimizle çalışmalarımızı
kuvvetlendirip dünyada Yeni Hayat
potansiyelleri yaratmaya devam ediyoruz
ama buraya kadar belki iyi duyuluyor
olabilir Biz Bizim için de aslında bu
anlattığım şeyler 1 dakika içerisinde
oldu ama bizim yaklaşık iki buçukla 3
yılımıza mal oldu ve biz bu ürünü
geliştirdikten sonra operasyonları
yapıyoruz tabii ki Ama o zamana kadar
şeyi düşünmemişsiniz Ee Çünkü daha
öncesinde kurumsalda çalışma fırsatı
bulmadık ya da hiç bir yerde farklı bir
şeyler yapmadık ürünü
Bu ürünü nasıl
finansal olarak Sürdürülebilir hale
getirecektik
hem başlı başına en büyük
karşılaştığımız problemlerden bir
tanesiydi Evet biz bunu yapacağız
ama farklı coğrafyalarına nasıl ulaştır
acak bu aslında sorduğumuz bu sorunun
cevabını
siz biraz daha insanlarda aradık şu anda
yoğun şehir hayatlarınız var ve bir
yerden bir yere koşturuyoruz adeta ve
doğaya çoğu zamanda doğayı ihmal
ediyoruz doğayı Dokunma fırsatı
bulamıyoruz ve Evin kapısından adamımıza
atıyor olduğumuz andan itibaren doğadan
bir şeyler almaya başlıyorsun Peki biz
de dedik ki biz burada adımımızı atıyor
olduğumuz andan itibaren her bir
attığımız adamı Her işlemimizi işte
Satın aldığımız ürünü veya işlemimizi
Doğada Bir ton topuna dönüştürüp doğadan
bir şekilde aldığınızı geriye
kazandırabilir miydik ve bu yüzden
aslında Eco drone işareti kavramını
yarattık örnek veriyorum bir pantolon
satın aldığınızda ürünün üzerinde bu
işareti gördüğünüzde o ürünün satışı
için bir ton topu atışı
gerçekleştirildiğini anlıyorsunuz bu
işareti telefonunuzun kamerasına
göstererekte uzaktan doğrudan tohum
tohum topunuzun tüm süreçlerini takip
edebiliyorsunuz Biz doğrudan da Burada
partnerlerinizle beraber etkinlik daha
kuvvetlendirerek Hem bizim uzaktan
doğaya dokunabildiğimiz ve doğadan
aldığımızı geriye kazandırdığımız ve
ekonomilerin bizim umudumuzu ve iklim
krizi mücadelelerimizi doğaya taşıdı bir
senaryo ya
evletmeye çalıştık Tabii ki iklim
krizini tek başına doğrudan
ormanlaştırma ve büyü çeşidiyle katkı
sağlayarak çözemeyecektik çözemediğiniz
ile alakalı Hatta şöyle bir araştırma
var
iklim Türkiye'nin tamamını ormanlarla
kaplasak bile Türkiye'nin karbonuna
ikisini şu anda yok edemiyoruz iklim
krizinin tek bir sebebi olmadığı gibi
tek bir çözümü de yok ve bunu göz önünde
bulundurarak da biz alternatif olarak
neler geliştirebiliriz
ve Burada gördüğünüz aslında bir mobil
uygulama da geliştirdik bu da az
bireylerin iklim krizine karşı mücadele
edebilecekleri Ee mobil uygulamanın
içerisinden aldıkları çevreye duyarlılık
görevlerle Eee görevleri doğrulayıp
edindikleri puanlarla ihtiyaçlarını
karşılayabilecekleri ve aynı zamanda
iklim kriziyle mücadeleye edip karbon
ekiplerini azaltabileceği bir ürünün
yetiştirdik buradaki motivasyonumuzu ilk
Türkiye'den başlattık Ee
ve her geçen gün kendimize soruyoruz şu
anda dinledikleriniz belki
sizlerin nasıl duyuluyor bilmiyorum ama
biz henüz hiçbir şey başarmış değiliz
bir şey başardık demek için doğrudan
krizi Ee yok etmemiz gerekiyor ve bu
yapılan çalışmalara doğrudan dünyanın
her coğrafyasında destek vermemiz
gerekiyor
problemle karşılaşıyoruz ve bu
karşılaştığımız problemlerde de Aslında
her geçen gün kendimize soruyoruz tüm
olumsuzluklara sorunlara rağmen iklim
krizine karşı Birliği olduğumuz
mücadeleyi ya kazanırsak teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]